yo well account to this video what can I
do to get in a tablet shape am really
out of sorts a little bit didn't get
anywhere in my live show yesterday and I
played to warm up games where where I
thought that my opponents were pretty
high rated but I thought they really
played badly I mean I still lost the
computer didn't confirm any of my
suspicions that is that their play was
bad so hmm kind of out of shape anyway I
decided to despite them the bad results
and the warm-up games to just fire up a
rated game and see what happens this is
some against yope from what is this
actually took hello Wow okay um and
we've got amarok see bind this is not
the most testing way to play it may be
from White's point of view okay well
this this kind of thing I don't know I
like for what um yeah I can go back at
all just need to trade bishops just yet
yeah this five-week six week break from
online chess from blitz chess is really
showing I am yeah I've really am
expected that it would be a bit tricky
but it's it's difficult to get out of
this slump it's not easy so okay well
here i'm getting the CFR which is nice a
purely on technical position would be
really welcome here simply something
that is simple to play mmm you came he
might go King age seven bishop age six
in this position okay well here I again
go Quincy seven and destroyed Queens I
think I can be I'm okay with that to
trade the Quincy em with the bishop and
more space it should be a good way to
play can do the Primo free capture even
though probably taking on c7 is not the
the best option that he has but it's a
sense of a premium to enter okay he did
to take so I'm going to play here to
prevent any night see for business and
let's go from here okay I'd like to go
air f form but at the moment he can
still go to g4 yeah after capturing it's
not that great but I have this move on
intending f4 if he goes g5 I can go g3
and then fo
where's he going the night has no square
unless I'm really getting into the yeah
Reza no he really had to ask ok I'm glad
to to have won 1 game here really helps
to get in stride yeah there is a regular
maroc see but a success bit uncommon
that move it's not let's say essential
in online so black is normally starting
with with this move or with Bishop to d7
and only later deciding if he wants to
move upon but ok well i played f3 which
is certainly not bad he took it and went
here yeah this is an interesting idea
what black sometimes can't rise to go
you're like Queen 85 rook FC eight and
putting quick pressure on c4 for b5 as
well I went here and after rook c8 I
went 95 pin which is a very thin sorry
very safe move however I'm not sure that
this is a good idea I think it should
take here that's that simpler something
like let's say if I take with the pawn
check thing like this should be a should
be okay for black I'd rather still be
why it a little bit because this pawn is
something where I can try to initiate
some players North got more space to
always liked but it's nothing terrible
can also take here and this is just
easier to play then to play against the
the bishop pair and I'm not sure about
95 we call it the night is not stable on
that square I can always kick it not
sure maybe night c5 him white is
definitely better
gentium here probably this was more
gaddis Quincy to c7 was certainly
influenced a little bit by my bed
results after my break that wanted to
play it very safe age 30 I was a good
idea given by the comp attending f4 yeah
it's difficult for black he can try this
to give a give a pawn like like night
see for activity but I'm going to do
this this kind of thing White has good
control to bishops of C file it's a very
nice position what I did oops that was
not intended what i did also keeps an
advantage but it's probably not as as
forcing as it could have been this is an
interesting choice it's given by the
computer no white is better but not as
good as in the game something like this
check now can that's a tricky tricky
position computer likes wide but the a
pawn in connection with the bishop here
can be can be super dangerous I tend to
believe the compy edge should be
deepened up and deep enough in
calculation to see if I can stop the
apron or not but that's something else
yeah here it gets its very very nice for
ye and after this I'm just winning the
peace however if he I know what he
should do I mean he can try something
oops something like that but this is
just very nice for white yeah the space
bishop pair and so on it's a very nice
position okay well thanks for watching